it's my pleasure today to introduce
professor vicente rafael who as you know
is about
as well respected and well known as it
is possible to be
in academia and we are really delighted
to be able to host him
in our modest brown bag series here at
yale
um many of you will know his justifiably
famous works on the historical
and cultural politics of the colonial
and post-colonial philippines
including modern classics such as
contracting colonialism
white love and other events in filipino
history the promise of the foreign
and motherless tongues he's also the
editor of several important collections
in southeast asian studies
and if you go visit the duke university
press website
and search vicente el raphael
you'll pretty much see that he is the
central core of their
post-colonial studies series um really
in some ways
brings duke's reputation in that field
uh
into fruition now me personally i
i first learned of professor rafael's
importance when i was a phd student at
cornell
when i had the privilege of taking
courses with benedict anderson and james
t
siegel and although ben and jim are
rarely impressed by
anyone they would always speak in
reverent tones when they would recount
the stories of their greatest student
vicente rafael
perhaps i would say the only of their
students who could encounter their
charisma
without being shocked into submission
the rest of us when we would meet jim
and ben would become
sort of silent to use a to use the way
jim
might phrase it would be we'd become
like corpses
in the face of their charisma but vince
it seems has been
able to harness the energy of their
teaching without becoming
devoured by it today's talk
offers a sneak preview of a forthcoming
book on the politics and aesthetics of
the duterte regime
it's entitled the sovereign trickster
death and laughter in the age of duterte
and that book will soon be published by
duke university press
please join me today in welcoming
vicente rafael for his talk entitled
duterte's phallus on the aesthetics
and on the aesthetics of authoritarian
vulgarity
and i will share the screen and once
this screen is shared
he will begin his talk it's really a
pleasure to be here
uh even if it's just a virtual kind of
meeting i i noticed
many many friends and uh colleagues that
i haven't seen in a while so
hello everyone uh thanks so much for
coming
um and again thank you for uh for
for facilitating this eric and chris uh
and and the rest of the students and and
and staff
at uh in fact at the southeast asia
program
as eric mentioned this is a talk
that spun out of one of the chapters of
my forthcoming book
and if you would like during the q
a to sort of expand uh some of the
uh arguments i make in this in this
chapter and and connected with
everything else i've been
trying to figure out in the book and you
know i'd be i'd be more than happy to
so uh let me let me begin
by uh first of all by locating my paper
[Music]
okay
one of the uh one of the uh things that
uh if if you've if you've sort of even
briefly been following
events in the philippines uh since the
election of duterte
uh one of the things two things you
notice one is that uh
he remains enormously popular despite
all the sort of
arguably disastrous and and
near genocidal policies he's adopted in
the philippines
and the second thing is that he's also
sort of remarkably vulgar
uh and and uh people have tried to sort
of establish the connection between his
popularity
and his vulgarity his obscenity and
i in this paper i i sort of try to try
to connect it to
as well in terms of
uh asking a very basic question which is
what are the
sources of this symbolic authority uh
how has he managed to occupy
such a central place in the imaginative
life of filipinos both
supporters and critics alike as well as
those at home
and abroad and one of the ways in which
the president lays claim to both
national and global attention is
through his stories and jokes i mean
he's a consummate storyteller
and so the humor comes as part of the
stories
that he likes to tell he's widely known
for his irreverence and
body humor that constitute important
elements of his governing
style and it's really that that i uh
def uh tortilla i want to connect to the
connection between his storytelling
abilities and his governing style his
stories reveal a reliance
on infective and an obsession with
obscenity
he also makes frequent references to
genitalia
his as well as those of his critics to
the delight of his listeners
he revels in what uh the philosopher
eshilma
an aesthetic of vulgarity that has the
effect of establishing a relationship of
conviviality between himself and his
audience
what results is a kind of intimate
tyranny
much of it centered on the tales of its
phallus as it encounters
the world so for example and here we
could
start with the next slide for example
in his campaign events in april 2016
duterte addressed the makati business
club which is about a sedate and as
conservative
a setting as you can imagine made up of
wealthy businessmen in the country
rather than talk about his economic
policies though he regaled
the audience with stories about his use
of viagra
so he says for example
well i'm separated from my wife annult
so i'm useless
so so i'm not useless i'm not paralyzed
what am i supposed to do with my goddamn
thing down there let it hang forever
well there's no drama going on i drank
viagra and then it stood up
oh let's not kill ourselves i am giving
it to you raw
i thought you were all the same age here
uh
so so he starts with the story right
uh and here you can see where duterte
shares with men
of a certain age and considerable
influence a story about his experience
uh of emasculation followed by
rejuvenation
thanks to a pill he regains his heart on
the material evidence of a phallic power
that he thought he had lost
laughter ensues as he discursively shows
to the men
a part of himself that should have been
hidden his obscenity consists
consists of making the private public
reaching below to connect with those
above it is this sexual politics
from below that binds duterte to these
men
along with a sprinkling of women who
join in the laughter
together they share a common fantasy
about the authoritarian phallus as
something
they can imaginatively access and the
prospective pleasures
of a drug induced erection beginning
with that of detertis
but as we shall see in other examples
below the
presidential phallus comes across not
only as an
instrument of pleasure but also as a
sign of
terror in another campaign stop at a
large sports complex
in quezon city around the same time 20
this is around
early 2016 duterte tells a story that
reverberated around the world and
some of you may have remembered this
particular tale
he says that while he was a mayor in
davao in 1989
there heard a bloody prison siege in
davao city
among the dead was one of the hostages
taken by the prisoners
a 36 year old australian missionary
jacqueline
hamill according to duterte she was
repeatedly raped by the prisoners
along with other women hostages before
being killed
but rather than evoke pathos the sight
of hamel's
corpse steers desire in the mayor and if
you can have the next slide please
all the women were raped during that
first assault
because they retreated the bodies they
used to shields
one of them was a corpse the australian
woman lay minister
to this was a problem when the bodies
were brought out
they were wrapped i looked at her face
son of a [__]
she looked like a beautiful american
actress son of a [__]
what a waste and son of a [__] here is
a very common
filipino curse what came to mind was
they raped her they took turns i was
angry because she was raped that's one
thing
but she was so beautiful the mayor
should have gone first
son of a [__] what a waste say young
okay so uh so much for that slide
he hamill's rape and death is used by
duterte as a step for
as a set up for a joke about himself
more specifically
about uh the arousal and frustration of
his
lust he sees her dead body and her
beautiful face and he feels that
he should have been the first in line to
assault her instead he comes too late
and isn't able to come at all it is his
failure to assert his claim on the
woman's body that is presumably taken by
his audience
as the object of hilarity seeing her
dead body fills him neither with rage
nor grief but with a desire that cannot
be fulfilled
he is unable to discharge his authority
as it were the horror of the scene is
just displaced
into a story about a mayor lamenting the
failure of his phallic power
rather than the erectile victory
celebrated in the first story
the second ends with the punchline sa
saiyan what a piri
preceded by the cuss word son of a [__]
but all is not lost detertis disclosure
of desire
unfulfilled and phallic authority
undercut
undercut produces a payback the audience
laughs and their laughter compensates
him for his lost power
it turns it turns returns to him it
returns to him
both the pleasure and the authority that
deal
uh that the dead prisoners and the
woman's corpse
had deprived him unable to pull rank
the mayor is nevertheless rewarded with
the people's recognition
of his narrative performance reports of
the story
drew sharp rebukes from feminists human
rights advocates
and the australian and u.s embassy as
well as many other quarters
but among uh most of the electorate his
popularity
soared horrifying his critics but
delighting his supporters with his
pungent shamelessness duterte's bad
language and obscene stories
were crucial to propelling him to the
presidency
in tracking his jokes we can see a set
of obsessions
built around the question who gets to
own the phallus
who gets to wield who gets to wield it
and for what purpose
here the phallus should be understood
less as a biological thing
synonymous with the penis as a symbolic
weapon for asserting
autocratic authority and patriarch
patriarchal prerogatives
over women and men alike like guns
cars or wealth the phallus can be used
to impress
and to threaten to unify and to disperse
to induce pleasure but also to coerce
submission duterte routinely threatens
to castrate his opponents
even as he repeatedly reveals his
generous endowment
used to avenge imagine hurts and sharp
fragile ego
duterte's phallus proved effective in
shutting down his opposition
the presidential phallus however is far
from being
an unassailable force as we saw in the
rape story
above it can also be blunted by other
men
and women whose death frustrated
duterte's assertion of his privileges
indeed duterte is notorious for joking
about rape as a way of reasserting his
ability
to police women's behavior and enlist
men
into affirming the sexism that
buttresses his authoritarian imagination
hence when critics point out that
contrary to his
claims crime in davao while he was a
mayor
had actually gone up especially rape
he retorts that wherever there are
beautiful women there will be plenty of
rape
along the same lines he also spoke
approvingly of men who had
quote the balls to rape candidates for
miss universe
in exchange for facing certain
punishment women are raped not simply
because they are women for duterte
it is because they are quote-unquote
beautiful it is as if their beauty is a
challenge
that has to be faced down a provocation
its proper place under the rule in the
service of the phallus
the philosopher kate mann has a very
interesting and useful description
of misogyny and perhaps let me just
cite it here as a way of framing
duterte's own particular
misogyny she says quote misogyny is what
happens when women break ranks
or roles and disrupt the patriarchal
order
they tend to be perceived as uppity
unruly out of line or insubordinate
misogyny isn't simply hateful it
produces social costs on non-compliant
women
think of misogyny then as the law
enforcement branch
of a patriarchal order that makes
for a useful if rough contrast between
misogyny and sexism
whereas misogyny upholds the social
norms of patriarchy by patrolling and
policing them
sexism serves to justify those norms
largely by an ideology of supposedly
natural differences
between men and women with respect to
their talents
interests proclivities and appetites
sexism is bookish misogyny is combative
sexism is complacent misogyny is
anxious sexism has a theory misogyny
wields a cajun close coat
in joking about rape duterte and here we
can
go back to me in joking about rape
duterte upholds
patriarchal norms and sexist attitudes
by wheeling the code cujo of misogyny
and that kojo that kajol is the phallus
at once
combative and anxious always wary of
challenges
and eager to assert itself one
particularly
disturbing story that illustrates the
law enforcement role
of misogyny involves duterte encouraging
soldiers
when confronted with communist female
fighters
to spare their lives but to shoot them
in the vagina
coat there's a new order coming from the
mayor we won't kill you
we will just shoot your vagina so that
if she has no vagina
then she would be useless close coat
shooting them in their vagina
was in a way taking away what made them
women
it was their punishment for taking up
arms and defying the state
it amounted to castrating those who
challenged the patriarchal norms
integral to the exercise of the state of
state's authority
hence we see how duterte's misogyny is
directed
not at every women but at particular
women
who attempt to seize the phallus for
themselves daring to go against this
political
and sexual authority and conversely
women who
affirm hispalic power are are richly
rewarded for that reason
now detertis phallic power is directed
however
not just at women but as we saw above at
other men as well to make sure that they
too
fall in line for example while
campaigning for
senatorial candidates during the midterm
elections
of 2018 duterte extolled the size of his
penis
in order to set him apart from the ugly
candidates
running in the opposition
while one's character is important penis
size he claimed was crucial
had god given him a small penis he
continued he would have gone to
to the church alt altar and cut it off
saying
son of a [__] is this all you have
given me encouraged by the crowd's
laughter
he then recalled how he would walk
around naked in the hallways
of the ywca as a young man while
everyone else covered up with a towel
he went about proudly displaying his
junk
junk the other residents would look on
in admiration
coat and here you could show the next
slide please
coat they tell me son of a [__] duterte
you're so hard when i was young my penis
almost
looked up to the sky moving the
microphone upwards to make
the point its head would almost reach
his belly button
i'm very thankful to my father at least
he let me out into the world
highly equipped close coat he finishes
by recalling how women
at a local bordello were shocked at the
sight of his member
they ran away they said referring to me
we don't like him
that skinny guy he won't stop having sex
close code
and so much for that slide in his youth
duterte claims he literally stood out
creating a vivid impression among both
men and women
while men envied his penis women however
ran away in fright wishing to have a
phallus like his
the other men acknowledge duterte's
possession of its power precisely for
the respect it arouses
in other men and the fear of sexual
violence
it steers among women merging
masculinity with misogyny
duterte's phallocentric politics is
central to his authoritarian imagination
using the image of his penis to put both
men and women
in their putative places this brings to
mind
helen sigsu quote within the
phallocratic apparatus women are
subordinated and defined by lack
while men are given the grotesque and
unenviable fair
fate of being reduced to a single idol
with balls
of clay close coat we could further see
duterte's phallocentric politics at work
in the following example in a speech in
duterte reacted to the rumors that he
had a kidney transplant
and was dying from colon cancer the
target of his ire
was kit tata former cabinet minister
during the marcus regime
and a major figure in the ultra
conservative catholic sect
opus dei in his newspaper columns he had
written about the turkish illness
and frequent absences from public view
suggesting
that he was on the verge of dying the
tartar
responded by saying and here we can go
to the next slide
this tata he said
he said my day is coming that i was
confined
serious in and out of the hospital with
colon cancer
nearly every day he was going on and on
you read the newspaper
i mean how unfair can you get every day
even i started to believe it so one day
one day i had dressed to take a shower i
held my
without my underwear i held my anus i
smelled it
smelled like [__] and not some other dot
dot next slide please
yeah he said i was already dead so i hit
back
i said this tata you talk son of a [__]
i would admit it if i was sick you son
of a [__] you have serious case for 30
years of diabetes
you your dick can no longer and then he
raises the microphone
to the laughter and applause of the
audience when you have diabetes
30 years drops the microphone no more i
said
let me borrow your wife for one night
i'll let her hold my body
go on your insult hurt a lot you son of
a [__] you're asking for it
you said i was rude well son of a [__]
that's true
you said i was no statesman well that's
true okay
so uh so much for that slate
um now let's break this down for a
second the president has always been
particularly sensitive about rumors
regarding his health despite the fact
that his various illnesses have been
widely reported
and takes particular umbrage at those
who suggest that he is close to death's
door
duterte takes his revenge in the form of
returning tata's putative insults
with interest but he takes his time
getting there
he recaps the rumor acknowledging its
power to compel belief
through its repeated circulation uh and
it's this it's this recapping
that's part of a storytelling uh sort of
style
to make sure that he doesn't have colon
cancer he talks about
poking around his anus and smelling his
fingers reassuring himself that it
smelled of [__]
rather than of some other cancerous odor
discursively exposing his anus
he also exposes himself not only to the
possibility of being sick
but also to the possibility of being
duped
assured that his anal stink is nothing
out of the ordinary
he goes on the attack punctuating his
remarks with crisp invectives
he points out that it is in fact tata
who has been ill with diabetes for many
years
and as a result can no longer get his
uten or
dick up the consummate performer that he
is duterte makes a point of illuminating
this
with the use of the microphone as a prop
he lifts it up and down
to show the contrast between what he can
do with his penis and what todd can no
longer do with his
he goes from exploring his anus to
scrutinizing his penis
linking the two as signs of his good
health and to clinch his case
he asks to borrow ta-da's wife so he can
verify the hardness of his erection
as compared to the flaccidness of that
dogs his mouth
and anus come to the aid of the
presidential phallus
together they marshal a barrage of
obscenities
that meets with the laughter and
applause of the audience
in this way duterte effectively unmanned
his opponent
tatad's stories depicted duterte in a
state of bodily crisis
feeling aggrieved the president hits
back showing that in fact
he remains in command beginning with his
control
of the narrative and his avail ability
to
reverse its target returning the insult
with interest
duterte draws a third person into the
scene tata's wife who is pictured as
complicit
in duterte's revenge in effect
cuckolding her husband
with the invitation for her to grasp his
thing
i have one last story and perhaps it is
the most revealing instance of duterte's
power
of storytelling and he is a little bit
extended so
i hope you'll you'll indulge me um
and it's i it's always kind of ironic
when i do this paper so because i talk
about
duterte's storytelling by telling my own
stories anyway
uh this story of being uh it is this
story that he's totally obsessed when it
comes back
or comes back to over and over again
which is
the story of being sexually abused at
around the age of 14
by an american jesuit priest during
confession
he often returns to the story as a way
of casting aspersions
at the catholic church that has been
critical of his human rights abuse so
there's a very
strategic reason for him to go back to
the story again and again
folded into his story however is another
his sexual abuse of their household help
which he later confesses
was in fact a fabrication here what we
see is a double confession in the story
duterte to the priest and to the
audience
and a double assault the priests on
duterte
and duterte on the maid the two acts of
violation
turn out to be intimately related
whereby the priest's assault on duterte
becomes a means for the latter's
domination of his audience
he has frequently told stories on he has
frequently told these stories on various
occasions
in his usual mix of taglish visaya
and english below what i provide
what follows is a translation of a
composite version
of this this this one long continuous
story so let's start with the slide
now in ateneo uh who here is from ateneo
if you are from ateneo on friday it's
communion
confession that's automatic and during
confession
bless me father for i have sinned and
what is your sin
well it is standing up because you are
fondling my goddamn prick
while confessing the priests fondle our
balls
so when you confess i ask you what are
your sins my son
i was a freshman what was the sin of a
freshman
next slide please i i
come on i i i i
is not a sin we do not have the whole
day speak up
i went to the what i went to the room of
the maid why
i lifted the blanket and i tried to
touch what was
inside the panty and i was touching she
woke up
so i left a room where did you go after
that to the bathroom
why guan father young the usual well
father uh the usual next slide please
what is the usual allah you know okay
so you went back and i tried to insert
my finger father
then i there was hair and and
it was wet and did she wake up no
father she was closing her eyes fast
asleep
the priest said and i went to the
bathroom again
father again yes father twice
oh my god say five our fathers five hail
marys because
you will go to hell next slide please
that is the explanation behind the
finger story the priests would urge you
to tell more sins
what sins could first second and third
year students commit
wolf whistling women was the only sin
that we committed
but father falvi he was always urging
you to tell
him more sins come on come on give me
your sins
do you know why because the longer you
stay there the more he can fondle your
balls
and there were many priests they would
just divide the students among them
if you believe the story that i fingered
a woman you're crazy
i only said it because the priest was
insistent
that we tell him more and more sins so
we could stay
kneeling while he squeezed our balls son
of a [__] that's the truth
uh so much for that slide so we we can
go back to it to me
um so what do we make of this really i
mean it's a really interesting story
now many of the turta's stories are
arguably confessional
to the extent that they are about
exposing what usually stays hidden
bringing to light what otherwise remains
in darkness
the subject who speaks is also the
subject who is spoken about
as she reveals the story of their sinful
acts to a priest who
in turn dispenses penance in the name of
god
as the mediator of divine forgiveness
the priest exercises
an inordinate amount of power over the
penitent
registering the penitence debts and
prescribing the penance with which to
cancel
these a subject of course that i talked
about in my earlier work
however in duterte's telling the very
act of confession
is subverted it is no longer meant to
seek forgiveness
and acknowledge the priest's authority
but precisely to ridicule it
duterte reveals the priest's
concupiscence
showing how confession becomes a vehicle
not for forgiveness but for clerical
abuse
confession breeds obscenity rather than
divine dispensation
making for an uncanny encounter between
the priest and the penitent
what emerges in the experience of
confession for the penitent
and here a young boy is the return of
the repressed in a familiar form
the predator as father or the father is
predator
from the perspective of the boy the
father's demands
appear autocratic he cannot be refused
this lust for the boy requires that the
latter must stay longer in the
confessional
making up sins in order to satisfy the
priest
to comply with the priest's demands
duterte claims he made up a story about
fingering their housemate then
masturbating twice in the bathroom
he evokes a circle of touching while the
priest fondles his genitals
duterte talks about fondling himself on
the genitals
of fondling himself on the genitals of
the woman as she sleeps
then subsequently fondling himself
his story connects these improper
connections
into a sequence of submission and
mastery that yields pleasure and
laughter
the trauma of sexual abuse for duterte
at the hands of the priest is transmuted
into the excitement of
probing the maid's genitals than
mastering
as it were his own this mixture of fear
shame and excitement is registered in
duterte's
stuttering reply to the priest's
insistence that he tell him more and
more
i he says as the priest holding his
balls
fishes for more demanding and then
and the turtus confession climaxes as it
were
with the two trips to the bathroom to
relieve himself in the end
the priest waves him off with a few
feckless prayers
assuring him of eternal damnation rather
than the sight for the
for the contrition and divine
forgiveness
confession here is converted into a kind
of pornographic machining
for the reproduction of sadistic male
pleasures
duterte submits to the clerical abuse
but turns that submission
into a story about his mastery over the
maid who remains
apparently innocent of his violation his
exposure
and disempowerment by someone above
becomes the condition
for over conditions become the
conditions for overpowering
someone below he thus reverses his
position
from being abused to being the abuser
from a position of submission to one of
domination
from one of fear to one of satisfaction
and release but only at the expense and
through the exploitation
of a subordinate other well what if the
audience
feminists human rights advocates church
hierarchy and other critics of duterte
typically reacted with anger they
decried his misogyny of making light of
his sexual abuse
as consistent with the disregard with
his disregard for human rights
others were scandalized by his indecency
and filthy language
his lack of delicadessa or civilized
behavior
in other words they read duterte's
obscenity in the way that he had meant
it
as an unremitting war on social
conventions
judging from the transcripts and the
videos however those who were present at
his speeches reacted differently
they doubled up in laughter they
applauded his stories
laughed at his jokes why would this be
now freud once posed this question
when we laugh at jokes what are we
really laughing at
are we responding to the technique of
joke telling or to the content of the
joke
or to both it is never clear he says
to the extent that jokes like dreams are
fulfillments of the same wish
to evade repression quote the joke will
evade restrictions
and open sources of pleasure that have
become inaccessible
it will further bribe the hearer with
its yield of pleasure
into taking sides with us without ever
without very close investigation reason
critical judgment suppression these are
the forces against which a
joke fights in succession
now the political significance of jokes
the fact that they go
against the grain of the reasonable and
the normal
would seem to make the valuable
resources for the oppressed
seeking to overthrow the weight of
authority mikhail battin further
argues that medieval celebrations like
the carnival
and modern literary forums like the
novel are sites for this
upending of hierarchy through satire
satire
disguise and social inversions the high
is brought down low
and the low is elevated especially parts
of the body
and its functions
writing is audience duterte is a like
is like a smuggler of illicit goods
promising forbidden pleasure
and overturning repressive strictures he
says that they would have wanted
he says what the audience would have
wanted to say but could not
their laughter could thus be read a
science of their identification
with duterte's efforts to find a way out
of his suffering
at the hands of the priest with the tale
about abusing the maid
who nonetheless remains unaware of her
violation they delight in his resistance
and at his bumbling attempts at mastery
that leads to some sort of self-recovery
decades later when he tells his story he
is no longer a boy
but the president of the country
occupying the heights of power
he is capable of commanding attention
wherever he goes
and whatever he says duterte's
obscenities
feel subversive but subversion in this
context
is in the service of an autocratic end
where laughter produces an intimacy
between ruler and rule the vulgarity of
this language
positions him as a kind of rebel
inviting others to join him in his
assault
on bourgeois sensibilities and norms but
it comes with the condition
that the audience must submit to his
narrative
only he can tell the stories and expect
expect their laughter
the reverse is never possible as no one
as far as i know
jokes with duterte in public he expects
no narrative
reciprocity no return with interest but
only a kind of
passive acceptance of the surplus of
stories he gives you
there is thus nothing democratic in
duterte's humor
instead the pleasure that the audience
gets from the jokes
is intrinsically linked to their
willingness to participate
in the imaginative violation of others
especially women
whether he seeks revenge or release
duterte's tales
seek to assert his phallic power over
his enemies
while simultaneously subordinating and
overpowering his audience
and looking at the narrative structures
of these jokes we see
how it hinges not only on the classic
techniques of joke telling
those of condensation and displacement
as in dreams
it is also productive of a hierarchy of
listening
whereby duterte as the teller
monopolizes the time
and the language of telling as part of
the audience
you have no choice but to wait for him
and he is
always late always late and then
listen to him take his time unspooling
his tails
unable to leave without drawing his ire
you remain a captive
audience jokes then become a way of
establishing his authority
he exposes himself renders himself
vulnerable and risks
dissolving his authority but only to
recover and reassert his mastery
over the scene of exposure this
dialectic of disclosure
and domination allows him to forge a
tyranny of intimacy
extracting your consent registered by
your laughter
humor is just a means of playing out his
anxiety
while assuaging his fear vulgarity
is stylized and obscenity performed to
release
the audience audience's inhibition at
defying conventions
but bogus and deeply conservative
since it always comes to the price of
submission to duterte's authoritarian
imagination
while laughter creates conviviality and
community
it is always shadowed by violence and
fear
duterte recreates in every story
something of the tone
and texture of his primal scene the dark
confessional where he is held captive at
the hands of an american priest
indeed his performative shamelessness
today
may be read as the unfinished struggle
to master his fear of the father
predator as he attempts to take on the
latter's power
for himself it is precisely that same
phallic power
that he seeks to grasp and wield when he
addresses those who considers
critical of him such as women and lesser
men
and especially abject figures of
criminality like
drug dealers and users recklessly
cussing at them
he lusts after their deaths brooking
neither dissent
nor opposition end and then
end thanks a lot
that's it thank you
uh it's raphael elvis for a fantastic
talk
um we'll take a moment just to um
use our hand clap functions um this is
really quite wonderful
um so we will now open up to a question
and answer period uh
i will moderate um the the q a here um
so if anyone has any questions i'd like
to ask you to
um use the hand raise function if
possible
and if that's not possible to uh turn on
your video and wildly wave your hand so
i can try to see you
but that doesn't always work because i
can't see every face at once
so let's get started does anyone want to
start us off with the first question
yeah so you know what i find most
curious is
this tremendous popularity that duterte
continues to have do we know is that
gendered
do women support him as much as men
um you know as far as i can tell uh
yes the popularity holds
as much across genders as far as i can
tell i mean of course there's
there's all kinds of nuance and you know
these surveys are are
really difficult to to to uh uh
figure out uh but but uh
both anecdotal and survey results seem
to suggest
that uh duterte remains uh popular and
there was there was
a survey late last year uh which put his
popularity as
far up as 91 ridiculous amount
uh you know and it hasn't really gone
down despite
his uh mishandling of the covid
the covet crisis and and and the sort of
failed rollout of
of vaccines and so forth uh he just i
mean
and part of it is because the opposition
is also so weak
uh the opposition hasn't been able to
offer uh an alternative
narrative much less better jokes uh than
duterte so he
he for that reason i think he remains uh
astoundingly astoundingly popular so
just a quick follow-up i mean it seems
that some of there's a kind of release
of from a sense of humiliation quite
often when you have this kind of
reaction
reactionary humor and um
i it's i mean from my time
you know in living among the science in
mindoro there was uh
systematic humiliation by be educated
and by the church and by
you know the the kind of targets that
trump also has similar
uh targets here absolutely um and it now
that kind of class humiliation would
seem to override the the gender
um right the the the is
as many women feel humiliated by the
elite
as men do and yeah if the
yeah it's like owning the liberals in
this country
if he upsets the educated classes then
that's that's enough
yeah and the other complicating factor
here is the church
um so so the source also comes from from
church hierarchy yeah you know so yeah
thanks for that great question and
answer um we have a question from paul
sarno then after that it will be john
cydell
asked miss roonebu amy chang and
ubert i thought there was a time when he
called
president obama quote a son of a [__]
yeah did a translation problem there
what exactly did he say well you know
the term he uses is putangina which is
the most common
literally puta
yeah so people tend to translate as that
but i mean
in the case of obama and others where he
uses that term you can easily translate
as [__]
you know which is the other common way
of referring to him
and of course it's always laced with a
racist uh
connotation especially when he
criticizes black leaders
there's always a racist undertow to it
as well yeah
and when he did he call ambassador
goldberg the that jewish ambassador
yeah that was the reaction to that yeah
not only jewish ambassador but a bakla
which is to say a gay uh bakla which is
to say gay
gay ambassador gay yeah what's that
about
well i mean i mean goldberg was i mean
as far as
was gay he was he was out uh
but uh filipino sort of used that
against him
and with duterte his relationship to uh
homosexuality is
it's a little bit complicated he's both
homophiliac
when necessary and homophobic
uh then called for so he could do either
of both
so he will flirt with uh for example a
gay audience
uh and even claimed that at one point in
his life he was probably gay
and then and would say things like well
i'm really for gay marriage because i
think people should be
able to marry whoever they want but then
at another point
use gay slurs to attack his enemies
right uh call attention to the size of
their butt and what you know
what they do with it and blah blah blah
blah blah so he's very
deceptive in that sense
thanks we have a question from john
seidel
yeah thank you uh eric and uh really
nice to see you vince and to get a taste
of the
the forthcoming book real pleasure um
two questions one is uh
sort of a if you could sort of follow up
on what you were
saying in response to tom gibson about
the church
um you know if we think of uh
bhaktihin's argument
about that rabalaisian laughter that the
irreverence
is kind of productive of
of something politically that challenges
authority
clearly the churches is somehow very
strongly in the mix and it's worth
perhaps noting that kit
todd is famously uh a member of opus dei
and and i wonder they're also the
comments you know that duterte made
about the pope
and even obama one could think of obama
as a rather
pious you know kind of persona and
uh and duterte's predecessor
uh aquino although
you know promoting a reproductive health
act that
the church opposed was also a kind of
churchy
mama's boy uh ateneo educated and all
the rest of it
so that's one question the second
question is um you
you use that that sort of classic phrase
uh
i think which which i've seen in other
contexts like in
in sweden when people talk about
populism there's a book in swedish that
something like
we say what what you're feeling that
sense of of
the of speaking what people are
really thinking but but are not allowed
in polite society to express
and the pleasure the vicarious pleasure
of that
transgressive speech act and behavior
and that that seems to be something
which scholars of
of populism um see in many contexts so i
guess i'm curious whether
you you might be tempted to extrapolate
from duterte
for other populists like i think there
was someone in recent memory in
american history but i i can't really
remember where
that might have been i think i i blanked
it somehow
yeah we all wish we could um i
first of all the question of the church
you know the church remains as one of
the staunchest upholders of
a certain kind of moral authority in the
philippines has a long history of
of uh a sort of uh sort of
uh critiquing political figures
all the way back from the spanish
colonial period uh to
you know most recently the marcos regime
and and then again duterte
so the church has sort of positioned
itself as the moral voice
uh that will uh criticize duterte
especially his war on drugs
uh his uh his pronouncements on on
women uh his violation of human rights
et cetera et cetera
and since since the country is largely
catholic
they do continue to enjoy a certain
amount of influence
and duterte has done something very
smart which is he sort of done an end
run
around the church and called them on
their corruption which is
every it's kind of like a public secret
well everybody knows the church is
corrupt but then no one will talk about
it
and so what he's done is he's he he's he
he's capitalized on this public secret
you know he's criticized bishops for
having cars for having mistresses
this and that uh and then of course
there is this deep down
sort of primal story in this background
of being abused
that uh i'm almost certain many people
uh share
uh and comes at a time when of course
there's this
huge explosion of of revelations you
know that i guess this would be
the me too version of the church abuse
right uh
kids being abused and so forth so so it
it comes at a particular conjunction
particularly historical conjunction
where the church is right for being
critiqued
right so that's one thing and duterte is
just the man to do it because of course
what's what's the church going to do
right they can condemn him to hell and
he says
things like oh i'd rather go to hell
because the women there are more
beautiful
you go to heaven you know the women are
ugly what am i going to do in heaven
right so uh you know he has a comeback
for everything
in that sense uh that that people think
about
but would never ever uh for one minute
say in public uh the second thing about
about uh
your question about humor uh and uh
you know i i mean think about the guy
you didn't want to whose name you did
not want to
mention i mean trump uh became very
popular
mostly because of his involvement with
mass media
and one and one of the things that for
me one of the most memorable
uh things about trump is he was very
much involved in in wrestling
and world and i'm sure you've all seen
the video of trump wrestling
uh doing these fall moves uh uh with
vince mcmahon uh and it's that kind of
of
wrestling aesthetic which is braggadocio
humor
defying convention uh a kind of
exorbitant display of phallic
masculinity
uh which which allows uh certain kinds
of people certain kinds of men
and also women i think to revel in
things that
are otherwise censored or forbidden i i
think that these are crucial elements of
a certain kind of reactionary
reactionary politics and and uh
the pleasure of fascism if you will the
pleasures of fascism
are not to be downplayed uh because
it's it's something that's that's that
permeates i think it's something that
permeates the culture
and then coagulates and crystallizes
around certain pronouncements of certain
figures
uh and then they become they become
these celebrities
right so uh so i think it's interesting
to think about that it's exactly
and and in this book i have i do have a
chapter
where i compare duterte with trump
precisely around
the question of of uh humor this kind of
repressive
humor so
thank you next question from asmus
before
before we ask the question i just want
to note that we
have professor rafael has agreed to stay
till about 1
20 today so i think we can make it
through all the quests
the questions listed in the chat there
but
um just do be mindful of the time as we
go through that go ahead osmos
oh thanks i'll try to be um concise
because i'm i was really taken with your
um
your analysis and it was many
interesting parallels to make to
uh in contrast to make to figure like
najib
in in malaysia um but i was also
really wondering about what kinds
of female figures feature in duterte's
stories and what kinds of patterns are
tied to that
because it strikes me that there's a
quite different
uh tenor to the way he speaks about his
violation
of its imaginary violation of the maid
and the
sort of almost celebration of the
violation of the
australian uh woman in the other story
yeah and and so i wonder because like
at least where i have done field work in
malaysia like all sorts of stories about
rape and and sexual violation would
always be
um related in some way or sort of
touch upon themes of spiritual danger of
witches
and especially the
always fascinating figure of the
pontiana so i was wondering what kinds
of
figures are present and what kinds of or
even if
ideas of witches and and which is sexual
danger are also involved
yeah it's a good question as far as i
can tell
uh he doesn't delve into these uh
sort of uh supernatural figures for
women
uh duterte's stories are sort of
uh pretty secular in their telling as
they were
uh and so uh i mean the malaysian stuff
sounds a lot more interesting
in many ways uh but duterte doesn't
doesn't dip into this
why he doesn't i'm not sure why uh but
i'm sure if you dig
deep enough there'll probably be some
kind of resemblances family resemblances
to
to these different ways of of uh
sort of figuring uh femininity
and femininity out of place because
that's always what's at stake
right it's it's always the female figure
out of place
and how you deal with that that's always
an invitation they're too beautiful
they're too ugly they're too wild
they're tube rebellious whatever
so this this idea of the female out of
place
is always an invitation for duterte to
sort of step in and say well
i'm going to put her back in place you
know which i mean arguably is the
substance of misogyny
that the cape mann suggests in her in
her uh book
so yeah
uh next question from amy chang um hello
thank you so much i had a related
question about your final anecdote which
um like pretty much everyone else i'm
sure i heard the first time in the news
and had like a really
strongly negative reaction to but um i
was surprised
uh listening to your analysis it really
opened up a lot of the
vulnerabilities that are present in that
story and
i wanted to ask about a few more things
in particular
um for instance how precedented is it to
be open about
clerical abuse or like child abuse
uh for like male figures politicians or
just any other celebrities
um and then the second thing was um
i was curious about like the positioning
of fabrication and innocence in that
story because
he says like if you think i really did
it then like you're crazy of course i
didn't and he explains that he was
telling the story sort of as a survival
strategy like when he was being abused
as a
child to please this priest but also to
sort of like
it seems like as you were pointing out
with the circle of touching like
he's trying to tell the priest that like
what the priest is doing to him is a sin
by positioning himself as a sinner and
saying that he's
touching someone else and therefore like
if you call this
like this masturbation of an unwitting
victim
a sin then you should recognize that
what you're doing to me is a sin and
like
each time he goes to the bathroom i
assume to come it seems like he's trying
to like
bring the tail and thus the experience
to a close so that the abuse will be
over but like it in each case like lasts
longer than he wants it to so he has to
like continue telling the story again so
that he can get them to the payoff and
in that i sort of hear
an accusation of the audience as well as
like you're crazy if you think i've done
any of these things at all as asthma has
pointed out like the two
violation stories we heard today are
both imaginary violations
proposed violations that have been
fabricated
um so just yeah i was hoping to hear
more about your thoughts there and maybe
how like
what the position of the the innocent
woman who's unaware of the violation
that's happening is or like
in the previous case of the australian
missionary like the woman who has died
and so never could experience his
violation which is like clearly
constructed to be imaginative
you know that's that that's a great
point and
now you make me think about the
connection between the dead woman and
the woman asleep
both of whom remain innocent uh of of
their violation and i think this is
again typical
of so much of duterte's stories whereby
uh his violation
is compensated by a story
rather the violation that's visited upon
him in this case by the priest
is compensated by the story of his
performance or his desire
to perform a similar violation but to
figures who then remain passive and
therefore
innocent so in other words it's as if
he's saying he wants to exercise power
but at the same time he claims to be
innocent of the consequences of that
exercise so that's that's one way to
read it
the second way to read it is and again i
don't get
as deeply into this as i probably should
which is that
uh you assume he's been traumatized and
the question of trauma of course is that
trauma is never resolved
right trauma thrives in repetition
because of its failure to fully
represent what's actually happened
so in the case of duterte he likes to
tell the story of being traumatized by
the priest
precisely because he can't quite get
over it right it's something that goes
on and on again in that sense
it probably resonates with the traumatic
experiences
of his audiences too that's what they
share what they have in common
is their inability to transcend their
trauma and therefore to be condemned to
repeat it
but uh the payoff is the fact that it's
repeated
but at the expense of certain figures of
power
in this case the priest or whoever it is
that's that's that's
that's traumatized them um and there's a
certain interesting
connection with his obsession with drug
killings
i mean you know when you hear him talk
about addicts
and killing i mean he basically it's the
same thing i want to kill as many of you
[__] as possible right i'm not
going to be happy until everyone's dead
right i want to kill kill kill kill kill
right
so it's it's this again this
repetitiveness this inability
to be able to sort of find closure uh
and
and to return again and again to the
situation of wanting to violate
uh without end uh at the same time
to maintain that he is saving the
country by killing addicts
uh and in that sense uh sort of maintain
a certain innocence even a certain
nobility in what he's doing so it's
it's uh it's again this dialectic of of
disclosure and domination uh that he's
thrown back into as he tries to repeat
uh the same thing the same discourse the
same stories again and again
and this is what substitutes in case of
duterte this is what substitutes for
policy
he doesn't have any policies his only
policy is to act out
as it were uh his his trauma if if you
want to
i mean that's a little bit simplistic
but i i mean i think if you wanted to do
like a psychopathological
analysis of what moves this guy i mean i
think that's part of it
thank you um and then if i could also
ask like a brief follow-up
question i was wondering if you'd
noticed any um
patterns in his language use for
different parts of his story setups
because you mentioned he speaks in
taglish he's in english and are there
like does he
reserve a certain language for like
certain punch lines or like
for certain setups or like building
towards the climax
yeah he likes to speak in bisaya bisdak
bisdak is his first language and and
some of his most some of his most vulgar
uh
and and more more colorful anecdotes are
always in vista
uh the tagalog is his second actually
english is a second language tagalog is
his third and
taglish is probably his fourth right and
so when he speaks he tends to
he sends he tends to to navigate through
those different
uh kinds of of languages uh
and and it's the the like the the vagina
shooting the communist rebels in the
vagina which is
so horrific you can't even contemplate
it but he likes to tell that in bistak
so yeah thank you so much
thank you the next question is from uh
uber
leonard toralitsa
hello good afternoon and good morning
here in the philippines so
my question is uh my my my argument is
this because i have read about duterte
because i'm trying to write a poem about
his physicism because i'm a creative
writing student
from the philippines from updancer if
you're aware for if you know
because i have read about you you're
from ateneo if i
yes if i read it correctly so i
have the third day has been diagnosed or
was diagnosed with narcissistic
personality disorder so what do you
think
doctor loves to both about this penis so
is there any studies or theories why he
does this all the time and
one thing he's also diagnosed
with uh pervasive
tendency to demean humiliate others and
violate
other human rights so what do you think
about
that yeah yeah well i mean in some ways
this paper is about that it's about
reckoning with with these other
diagnosis
without completely accepting them i mean
i'm not i don't i don't need
the paper in fact i don't mean the book
to be reductive in that sense of
you know everything can be traced back
to this pathological or narcissistic
condition
but i do think that that uh it's
impossible to talk about duterte or it's
impossible to talk about uh sort of
these fascist figures without invoking
uh some of these psychic pathological
conditions uh that seemed to run
like a threat through many of them uh
the other thing and and this is also
actually this this thing
about the turtle's humor is part one of
a much longer chapter
on his uh what i call the presidential
body uh
kind of like a a tribute to uh what's
his name
the president's two bodies uh let's
listen to the guy who wrote that um
uh do you remember and
senator butler sir no no no no no the
the the the the political theorists are
about the president's two bodies i can't
gather them
anyway um i'm sure the political
scientists
around here will know uh anyway uh so
the second half of the paper is actually
about his
his uh frequent references to his
illnesses
he likes to talk about his illnesses he
likes to talk nobody else can talk about
his illness but he can
now he'll talk about his burgers disease
he'll talk about his
his uh possibility he has cancer
uh in other words he likes to talk about
his own mortality
and his own frailty in the same way that
he likes to talk about the abuses
that he's encountered in the past so i
these these are ways in which duterte i
think materializes
uh his own condition uh as
as a way of sort of anticipating
criticisms from his from his uh
opponents
he's too sick to rule that he's got all
these problems etc etc etc
he'll admit to them and he'll say well
so what you know
uh and and then and then he will wax uh
pathetic i mean he will
he he likes to invoke a certain kind of
pathology he's making support i can't do
everything
i'm probably gonna die probably gonna go
to hell and so forth and again
it's a way of sort of invoking a certain
kind of pity
on the part of his audience these are
two sides on the one hand
he he likes to joke and he likes to be
abusive
and he likes to be obscene on the other
hand he will admit to his own frailties
and his own mortality
as a way of anticipating criticism
criticism from his audience
so sir uh any follow-up sir uh do you
think duterte
say that to emotional blackmail the
whole nation oh without doubt
without doubt i think duterte's policies
of the drug killings
has has resulted in what i call a
government government of fear
right and again this is part of the book
is that how all these contributed
to a certain governing style where fear
is at the center right of everything he
does
thanks um the next question is from
orvin
mallory organ go ahead
learning professor um i
asked him this question like in relation
to uh
the southeast asian politics and culture
seminar that um i'm with professor harms
as well as some people in this class
um i remember one
like this talk really reminds me of um
one of the earlier readings that we did
on um uh ben anderson's japanese power
or the idea of power in japanese culture
specifically
um that won um one of the sections where
um anderson uses a really remarkable
anecdote
about um the succession crisis
of like a javanese um
the dead king's manhood standing erect
and
on top yeah you know that one yeah yeah
of course of course yeah
uh i was wondering like so you know
knowing you as a student of anderson
like you see
do you see like this whole fact like was
that part of your inspiration
in writing this um writing about duterte
and
i was to follow up on that like um as
professor harm said like um to ask you
about how would you rewrite
that piece as a visayan idea of power
yeah well yeah i don't know about that
that's that's another story we could
talk about later
but uh well certainly you know
ben has been an influence but but i
think much more has been the influence
of
certain feminist theorists who've talked
about
uh uh sort of uh phallocentric
or phallocentrism uh
and and uh that's been that's been more
important in this case
in connection to that i remember in
graduate school taking these classes
in uh pre-colonial southeast asia with
people like oliver walters and various
other people who some of you probably
remember
and they would talk about the lingam and
they would talk about the phallus
and there would be no connection with
the sort of
gendered politics and the sexual
politics of pre-colonial southeast asian
uh sort of practices and i always used
to think that's very strange
i mean you're basically talking about
representations of you know
male members as it were uh but but
but you can see how something like
duterte and duterte's
wielding of the phallus
is in some ways very southeast asian i
mean harks all the way back to
you know pre-colonial pre-colonial power
uh pre-colonial notions of power
which i don't make explicit in this
paper but i don't think it it's such a
stretch to make that connection so
yeah thank you
we have a question from daniel yanto
hello and thank you again it was a
really interesting talk um actually the
first words i
i learned in tagalog over in the
philippines was joklong
and i think it's an interesting aspect
of their culture but i also was in
manila and the provinces and i noticed
that the jokes were different
in each places so i was curious if you
found that duterte's
stories differed based on where he gave
them at
um no they were pretty consistent they
were pretty consistent yeah
yeah um i mean there are always
variations uh
i i and and and lots of improvisation i
remember once
uh watching him administer an oath of
office
to newly appointed local uh
leaders you know just the ceremony that
they come to the palace
and they all take their oath of office
uh and the person always does this
and he comes in and you know he's he's
famous for sort of being
looking disheveled so you know he's got
his barong which is the formal dress but
he's got the sleeves rolled up and he
doesn't say good morning
he doesn't say hi how are you he says
well you know i'm not feeling that great
i think i ate something bad i had to
i had diarrhea the other day
and now i'm really itchy my whole body
is itchy and then he calls on one of the
women
uh who's about to take that and says can
you come over here and scratch my back
i mean this is like apropos nothing
right he doesn't
no ceremony it's just like can you
scratch my back right here it's really
itchy right
and of course everybody's giggling
because wow president you know
wants you to scratch his back that kind
of thing or or he'll give a talk
in front of overseas contract workers in
korea
and he'll pull a woman and he'll say oh
what about giving me a kiss
you know and they're all like taking
selfies and so excited
and of course everybody else is outraged
about this
and but yeah he thinks nothing of it
right
and my favorite code is you know he he
he'll greet
overseas contract workers returning from
saudi arabia
and they'll say well it's too bad you
guys lost your job but you know what
i can give you a job why don't we go
kill addicts let's kill addicts
you know that would be a good job for
you
thank you very much yeah joke luck
originally had a question from roderick
gullum but he sent me a note saying his
question
was already asked and answered so we'll
go straight to
jim scott
hi jim
again jim you just need to unmute
briefly
can you hear me now yeah yeah good hi
jim
um hi vince i can't wait for the book
um so it's exciting to get a glimpse
into it
i had a a rather simple question
um and that is um
the use of the word joke
uh your stories don't sound like jokes
and they're it's a raccoon tour it's a
sort of personal history with
yeah all of the edges that you point out
but it's not the at least
the kind of maybe i'm uh
looking at it through two western eyes
of
a joke with a punch line and a sort of
suspense
and so on um and so it strikes me that
what duterte is doing
is maybe something other than a joke
that we need
a kind of special category
and that therefore it's a little odd to
sort of put it in the freudian joke
right category right um
anyway what are the other ways in which
one might think of what duterte
is doing and the
uh it also occurred to me to wonder
in for ordinary filipinos
um this kind of talk
would it be confined to
men drinking um
would it what what kinds of social
contexts would this kind of
storytelling be confined
were it not a kind of presidential
um repertoire
uh you're absolutely right this these
are the kinds of stories men
and some women would tell around
you know drinking sessions for example
uh and uh so it's not unusual
uh what happens though is that those
drinking sessions are usually
circles closed circles and it's it's
very rare that they they
come come across uh much more publicly
and in a way
you could argue that the tortoise
storytelling has
uh sort of sort of created
this has nationalized as it were
the drinking circle right which used to
be very local very small very intimate
uh he's he's turned an intimate
gathering
into a very public uh sort of uh
situation the second point you make is
extremely
interesting are these jokes properly
properly sort of thought of or is there
something there's another category
that we can use for uh you know i've
struggled with that
and one of the things that i use as you
can tell from the title of the book
is tricksterism right i mean and i call
i i refer to
duterte as a sovereign trickster uh as a
trickster figure
uh which which probably would be again
would connect to a more southeast asian
context
and and the thing about the trickster
figure as you know is
it's very widespread in the philippines
it's very widespread in southeast asia
there isn't a single
southeast asian country that doesn't
have some some
figure of the trickster and the
trickster is a very very
sort of uncanny or very canny figure i
should say
that combines uh aggressiveness with a
certain kind of attractiveness
that is funny but also cruel
that is predatory but also in some way
subversive
in other words all these different
characteristics that we associate with
duterte
you can find in the trickster figure
which is very different say from the
trickster figure that you might have in
native
american uh sort of contexts
but in the philippines the trickster
figure is is omnipresent
uh and i think that that's what you get
with duterte is is
not so much the concept well he is a
storyteller yes that's true
but not so much a jokester but more of a
trickster
and my use of freud is really an attempt
to in some ways
uh get at the politics
of this tricksterism of this jokester
because i i do think that freud is still
i mean it's
whatever criticism you might lodge
against him i i still do think that he
was very very
much uh keenly aware of the power of
of uh uh of not just storytelling but
of of humor uh and it's very interesting
because i hadn't read
i hadn't read jokes in their
relationship to the unconscious for
years for decades
and when i read it i was surprised i
think something like 80
of the jokes are anti-semitic i mean
they're all jewish jokes
you know and he revels in telling these
these and
these these jewish jokes uh and
and uh i mean it really it really struck
me as unusual so anyway that
that would be that so tricksterism and
then this idea of
sort of elevating a certain intimate
acts of
convention-defying exchanges to a
national level
thank you um we're approaching our 120
mark um and so i think i'll gracefully
bring it to a close here this has been a
really dynamic talk
followed by a really dynamic q a period
so i just want to thank you for that
before we say goodbye formally
you were mentioning drinking circles so
i thought i would take and
take a moment to um announce the the
next brown bag in
in two weeks uh on march 17th which will
be about
uh the melancholic play of alcohol
drinking lisu men on the china myanmar
border
so those of you who are interested in
this topic please
please join us with that said oh go
ahead yeah
just just one more thing about this this
little question of drinking and intimacy
uh i one of the one of the chapters in
the book
talks about the problem of intimacy in
the making of community
uh as it relates to
uh duterte's uh anti-drug
program you know as some of you might
know one of the ways in which duterte
duterte's policy works is through what
he calls operation tokong
that is to say he has the police in
conjunction
with local officials build a list of
actual and suspected drug users and drug
dealers
and these this list essentially becomes
the kill list and the question is how
does he develop this list
well he does so because everybody knows
everybody else in the community
it's through intimacy that you have the
development of
immunity so the very conditions for
creating community become the very
conditions
for exposing it to this sort of ongoing
danger
and for this reason rather than imagine
rather than imagine community that ben
anderson you know famously talked about
what you get in the philippines is what
i call an autoimmune
community a community of autoimmunity
you know where the community
uh in order to come into being actually
enacts the very things
that endangers it from within so uh and
and i think that is the tragedy
that is the tragedy and that is the
horrific sort of consequences of having
someone like duterte you know
do this authoritarian rule it's not the
first time and it's not going to be the
last time but with duterte you have
the most dramatic manifestation of this
auto indian community
so that's that's maybe a way to end this
that's a brilliant way to end it i'm so
just join me everyone and thanking
professor raphael for this fantastic
talk
i'll stop the recording now and then we
can just linger to say a polite goodbye